foreign  [Music]  in many Futures become a single pass  everyone Whispers nobody left  [Music]  you say one day we should have a baby  will right now baby I'm struggling we'll  see  say one day we should have a baby  well  God help me I love  I agree  [Music]  after all there's no way up for  everything well you and me we got better  pills they're ecstasy the Miracles the  crosses Miracles  crosses  Miracles and Crosses yeah how many more  songs I supposed to write before  I should turn it on and say good night  before  I turn it off and say good night  I have fears  [Music]  and she says some things from my past  make me feel powerless well  children and the Sinners and the animals  too and I  I pray for you  there's no way love for empathy will you  and me we got better pills with ecstasy  the Miracles the crosses  Miracles and Crosses  Miracles and Crosses  Miracles and Crosses Miracles and  Crosses  Miracles and Crosses  Miracles and Crosses yeah  [Applause]